[Applauso]
[Musica]
buonasera noi siamo le sorelle damiani e
questo è il frutto del nostro lavoro
avete sentito la sirena
questo è il suono che ogni giorno
all'alba da inizio alle nostre giornate
ma partiamo dall'inizio
la mia storia ha inizio da un cambio di
rotta a seguito di una telefonata
non è stato amore a prima vista
eppure oggi non vorrei fare altro
nel 1993
mentre stavo per iscrivermi alla facoltà
di medicina per inseguire quello che era
il mio sogno di diventare medico
ho ricevuto una chiamata da mio padre
mi disse che si trovava di fronte ad un
bivio
c'era da scegliere se fare degli
importanti investimenti in azienda
e quindi proseguire l'attivita
oppure continuare a fare come si era
fatto fino in quel momento e farla
finire pian piano
l'azienda è sempre stata per mio padre
la sua prima figlia perché nata nel 1968
prima delle sue due figlie in carne ed
ossa
quindi le sue parole mi hanno non poco
destabilizzata ma al tempo stesso mi
hanno fatto molto riflettere sul fatto
che non avrei mai potuto negare una
possibilità di vita a questa sorta di
sorella ea coloro che grazie alle
potevano sostenere le proprie famiglie
scelsi quindi il cuore mettendo da parte
quelle che allora erano le mie
aspirazioni
mi iscrisse alla facoltà di economia e
nel 1998 sono entrata in azienda
all'inizio le difficoltà sono state
veramente tante
[Musica]
purtroppo le difficoltà erano dovute al
fatto che dovevo farmi accettare
dovevo farmi considerare credibile
affidabile
in un mondo prettamente maschile
in più ero la figlia del titolare e
questo era ancor peggio se possibile
eppure lavoravo 20 ore al giorno
avevo l'impressione ogni giorno di dover
affrontare la scalata di una montagna
impervio stile
appunto per farmi accettare per essere
considerata una della squadra
lavorando così tanto tralasciamo quello
che quel tempo che prima dedicavo alle
mie amicizie allo svago in genere
oggi però posso affermare con orgoglio
che ne è valsa la pena
difficoltà sacrifici ma anche tanta
bellezza tanta passione
in questo lavoro di cui ci siamo pian
piano innamorate perché i colori
dell'ortofrutta i sapori profumi si sono
indissolubilmente innestati nel nostro
dna fino a raggiungere il cuore
sì perché mia sorella laura ed io siamo
convinte che un mestiere il nostro
mestiere tanto affascinante quanto
difficile non sia ereditario a
prescindere
lo scegli lo conosci e lo ami e allora
puoi sentirlo veramente tuo
nostro padre ci ha lasciato un ricco
testimone fatto di conoscenze di vario
tipo di rispetto della natura ma anche
di quanti se ne prendono cura e questo
ha richiesto a lui nel passato tanti
sacrifici ea noi ne richiede oggi
altrettanti e i sacrifici li fai se
svolge un lavoro con passione
siamo estremamente convinte che il
mestiere del contadino
e di quanti tutta la filiera che ruota
intorno alla terra
possa nel suo piccolo compiere un grande
miracolo siamo custodi della terra è di
tutti i suoi straordinari frutti e
attraverso un percorso di sostenibilità
e di
attenzione dell'ambiente
possiamo cambiare il mondo
e credo che lo sguardo attento e
meticoloso di due donne come noi che in
agricoltura sono cresciute può
contribuire in questa piccola grande
rivoluzione agricola
per noi l'azienda è casa è il posto dove
tiriamo fuori il meglio di noi e anche
il posto dove stiamo crescendo i nostri
figli
come è stato un tempo per lui
forse loro un giorno non sceglieranno
questo mestiere sicuramente però la
straordinarietà e la meraviglia di
questo mondo he sarà entrato nel cuore
[Applauso]
anche la mia storia ha inizio con una
telefonata
il giorno della mia nascita
mio padre filippo chiamò il suo socio
gino e gli disse sconsolato
è un'altra femmina
sì perché dopo la nascita di mia sorella
alessandra tutte le speranze erano
riversate sul secondo nascituro che
doveva per forza essere maschio per
poter proseguire l'attività di famiglia
purtroppo o per fortuna dipende dai
punti di vista
non fu così
oggi potrebbe sembrare medioevo almeno
in teoria perché nella pratica forse le
cose non sono poi così tanto mutate ma
la fine degli anni settanta pensare che
una donna potesse prendere le redini di
un attività di famiglia e soprattutto di
questo tipo di attività era considerato
bizzarro per non dire impossibile
anch'io come mia sorella avevo scelto un
percorso di studi lontano dal mondo
dell'ortofrutta volevo viaggiare volevo
conoscere il mondo
anche durante il periodo della scuola
all'università quindi avevo scelto la
facoltà di lingue dopo la laurea
avevo trovato un lavoro in germania nel
campo della pelletteria
da lontano però vedevo mia sorella fare
mille sacrifici e mettere da parte la
sua vita per il bene dell'azienda
una voce dentro di me mi diceva di
tornare a casa
diede ascolto a quella vocina
intrapresi un viaggio alternativo quello
nel mondo degli ortaggi
col passare degli anni la presenza delle
donne nel settore ortofrutticolo non è
ancora così scontata
e soprattutto si fa fatica a vederle nei
ruoli dirigenziali
mi devo correggere non è una questione
di presenza
pensate che il 70 per cento della forza
lavoro in ortofrutta è costituito da
donne
peccato però che solo il 12 per cento di
queste donne
ricoprono dei ruoli dirigenziali e
quando lo fanno
si fa fatica a trovarle sui tavoli delle
conferenze o dei dibattiti pubblici
se diventi mamma poi
è un disastro
è opinione comune pensare che una donna
una volta diventata mamma non possa più
fare le cose che faceva prima
e soprattutto che sia inconciliabile il
ruolo di mamma con quello di
imprenditrice
purtroppo un po e così se devi contare
soltanto sul welfare nazionale perché il
nostro non è un paese per mamme
lavoratrici figuriamoci se lo è per
mamme imprenditrici
[Applauso]
nonostante questo
mia sorella è dio
grazie ai nostri compagni di vita alle
nostre famiglie e anche ai nostri
collaboratori che non ci hanno mai fatto
mancare il loro sostegno
abbiamo scelto con grande consapevolezza
e gioia di diventare mamme
ci siamo scambiati i ruoli ci siamo
sostituiti
l'assenza di una è diventata presenza
dell'altra
essere diventate mamme poi ci ha aperto
nuove prospettive che questo lavoro può
offrire innanzitutto ci ha fatto capire
l'importanza di diffondere la cultura di
una sana alimentazione sin dalla tenera
età
e poi ci ha dato anche l'idea per una
nuova gamma di prodotti che in quel
momento non esisteva in italia quella
degli spaghetti vegetali amatissimi dai
bambini
la maternità che inizialmente sembrava
un freno un ostacolo è diventata una
grande possibilità oltre che di vita
anche di lavoro ogni ostacolo può
diventare una possibilità se affrontato
con il giusto piglio e la giusta forza
senza però mai dimenticare che siamo
donne con i nostri pregi ei nostri
difetti e senza mai scimmiottare gli
uomini
nel 2017 è nata l'associazione nazionale
delle donne dell'ortofrutta
un'associazione no profit che ha
radunato più di 100 donne che svolgono
questo mestiere
la condivisione delle esperienze ci ha
fatto capire che problemi che avevamo
affrontato noi e che avevamo superato
con tante difficoltà sono state
affrontate anche dal da altre donne e ci
sentiamo tutte un po meno sole ma c'è
ancora tanto da fare
innanzitutto da parte delle istituzioni
che attraverso un welfare più adeguato
devono consentire alle donne di non
essere sempre costrette a scegliere tra
lavoro e famiglia
[Applauso]
in questo processo in continuo divenire
anche gli uomini devono fare la loro
parte
non devono concederci spazio ma devono
riconoscere che la nostra presenza è una
ricchezza un qualcosa in più che nulla
toglie al loro ruolo le quote rosa sono
un fallimento
prima di tutto per gli uomini
perché sono un'imposizione
riconoscere la bravura dell'altro o
dell'altra in questo caso è simbolo di
grande perspicacia
così facendo non perderemo più tante
occasioni come è successo in passato e
come ancora purtroppo sta succedendo
oggi
mia sorella ed io abbiamo scardinate di
convinzioni di pregiudizi
anche creando un pri un team quasi tutto
al femminile
che ha capito che soltanto attraverso la
solidarietà e attraverso l'unità tra di
noi ce la possiamo fare
[Applauso]
questo invece è il suono della
confezionatrice automatica che a fine
giornata chiude i vassoi di ortaggi
freschi pronti per la partenza
ricorda molto il rintocco del pendolo di
un orologio che scandisce il tempo il
tempo che noi passiamo in azienda che a
casa per noi
gli impulsi ricordano i battiti del
cuore
quello che noi mettiamo
in tutto ciò che facciamo per fare al
meglio quello che ci hanno insegnato
siamo due donne due sorelle
due teste diverse ma un unico cuore che
batte all'unisono per l'ortofrutta
speriamo di essere da esempio a tante
donne coraggiose e intraprendenti come
noi che a volte purtroppo pensano di non
potercela fare
grazie
[Applauso]